bonjour antoine vous vous trouvez à
donetsk exactement quelle est la
situation sur place
oui bonjour alors je peux vous dire dans
un premier temps comment nous sommes
arrivés jusqu'à donner à ces sommes donc
venus depuis la russie nous avons passé
un point de passage la frontière un
point de passage terrestre nous avons
d'ailleurs nous avons passé hier dans
l'après midi entre 2h30 et 3h le temps
de vérifier que nos documents soient
vérifiés le temps également d'inspecter
notre véhicule et ce qui est d'ailleurs
le cas de tous les autres véhicules il y
en a beaucoup en effet donetsk est
lougansk sont désormais ravitailler
uniquement par la russie donc également
énormément deux camions à ce point de
passage est ensuite sur la route entre
la frontière et donetsk de nombreux
checkpoints des checkpoints qui ont
d'ailleurs été renforcée depuis le début
de l'année depuis donc cette hausse des
tensions autrement en ce qui concerne la
ville de donetsk pour le peu que nous
avons pu revoir pour le moment les gens
marchent dans les rues
les véhicules circulent et les magasins
sont ouverts une ville a priori qui
fonctionne de tout de façon tout à fait
normale
deux jours après l'annoncé d'une
possible rencontre justement entre
vladimir poutine et giove a et dan
comment est ce que la nouvelle a été
perçu à moscou
voilà bien sûr l'annoncé a été
accueillie de façon favorable le
ministère russe des affaires étrangères
dit se tenir à disposition du kremlin
pour organiser ce sommet et autres
signes positifs dans la foulée de la
conversation entre joe biden et vladimir
poutine le président russe a parlé au
téléphone avec le président finlandais
et on se rappelle que en 2018 en juillet
2018 c'était en finlande qu'avait été
organisé un sommet entre vladimir
poutine et le président américain qui
était alors donald trump
autre signe de désescalade on peut
l'entendre ainsi c'est la décision de
washington de finalement ne pas renvoyer
deux navires de guerre en mer noire les
autorités turques n'ont confirmé aucun
navire de guerre américain ne va passer
le détroit de bosphore dans les
prochaines semaines merci beaucoup
antoine pour toutes ces précisions
antoine claireaux en direct de donetsk